okay the ACS on we're good good morning
everyone I am very happy to have my
friend a lot Gil here you saw some of
you or all of you if you looked online a
talk yesterday about how to get meetings
with investors and raise money if you
would be so lucky as to get a meeting
with this investor and even more lucky
to raise money from him that would be a
really good thing for your company a lot
sort of an epic investor he's at an epic
career investing but he's much more than
that he's not only a fantastic investor
who's bested a lot of YC companies like
it seems like all the successful ones
and someday you have to figure out you
have to tell me how you figured out how
to do that maybe we can talk about that
today but he's also a start-up founder
he's worked it at Google and Twitter and
he is increasingly known as an author
claims it's not his career but he is an
author of high growth Handbook which is
a very cool book I recommend you all
read it but not maybe right while you're
starting your showed up maybe as your
startup gets going because a lot of the
topics in there will be relevant for you
hopefully in the future so maybe you can
start off the conversation by telling us
a little bit about you know how you got
from so how you got to where you are
today what's your journey to epic
investor and startup founder and and I
guess company whisperer sure so first of
all thanks for having me here and really
excited to be here for start of school
so you know I moved out here right after
graduate school and you know I moved out
I didn't know anybody many of my friends
decided to stay on the East Coast and so
I was sort of starting fresh when I
first came out here and I had terrible
market timing and that I moved out here
right as the entire internet bubble was
collapsing and so I went into an
environment where a year after I got
here most people were getting laid off
and most people were sort of desperately
looking for jobs and so somebody who was
a vice president
management was suddenly trying to get
any product manager job that could get
at any level at any company and so it
was a very odd environment and it was a
very tough one to plug into and this is
before things like YC existed there was
no online content or on starting
companies there was no content about
basically doing anything and so what you
had to do is really sort of hand-to-hand
combat in terms of networking meeting
people and sort of I basically talked my
way into a job by offering to work for
free at a startup and that's that was my
entree it was basically an unpaid labor
on behalf of a company as a way to get
my foot in the door and get my foot into
technology so that was that was
basically my starting point that's sort
of a good lesson for how even in today's
world where there's many more resources
for how you have to you have to really
pound the pavement and you have tits you
know it's it's elbow grease to get
started
lots of times right yeah absolutely and
I think what happened is after so I got
a PhD in biology so it's completely
irrelevant to software and technology
but I wanted to go into software
technology and so completely irrelevant
at the time to software in technology
relevant but it changed later right it's
changed and so basically my first
software startup job allowed me then to
be a software person and that was the
thing that allowed me to do a transition
actually moved out here to join the
telecom equipment startup as a product
manager so I worked on hardware and I
had to leave that company and then I my
way into working for free at a software
company and then I was selling a
software person and that's what sort of
led to me then eventually ending up at
Google and other places and so you ended
up at Google but let's talk a little bit
about because you you ended up working
at Google on Twitter but you started
companies in between and in the end sort
of sort of transitioned it to becoming
an investor how did that all happen yeah
so I joined Google in 2004 and
effectively started the mobile team
there so I helped buy Android and pulled
together their early teams for Google
mobile maps and mobile Gmail each of
which have hundreds of millions of users
but I had nothing to do with that since
I left before that massive growth and I
left Google to start a very early data
infrastructure company that was called
mixer Labs was a company
GIP I was a product name and that was
acquired by Twitter and Twitter bought
us when Twitter was about 90 people and
then my job quickly became one of
hopping the company scale from 90 people
to 1500 people over two and a half years
and so the prior is heard of super
growth journey I had before that was
actually joining Google at around 1500
2000 people and it had 15,000 people
over three and a half years so very
rapid growth when something's actually
working and then I left Twitter to start
another company called color genomics
which is a big data means genomics
company that's raised about 150 million
dollars in venture capital and was up
and running still here and growing in
and and finally made use of your PhD in
biology yeah thankfully so you're an
interesting mix of big company guy and
small company guy how do you how do you
think of yourself that's sort of unusual
isn't it yeah I guess I think of myself
as somebody who is good at operating
teams or driving efforts and it could be
a five person team or it could be a
multi hundred person team so that's it
that's my self actualization of what I
do I actually think there's a lot of
people who drop in and out of big
companies and startups in terms that
they start a company maybe gets acquired
they run a division they maybe go and
start another company or they become an
investor and so if you look at Silicon
Valley it's sort of littered with people
who've done this sort of back and forth
Ben Horace would be a good example of
you know joined a company which was
Netscape it went public he then started
a company it got acquired by HP ran a
big division at HP and then you know
co-founded in recent Horowitz but that
was you know a related career path in
terms of somebody who bounced between
the two it kind of puts the lie to the
the the trope that you have to uh you
have to fire the the entrepreneurial
you're either an entrepreneur or you're
a big company person but it's not quite
so simple is it yeah I think it's a good
point because I think there is a real
shift when Mark Zuckerberg hired Sheryl
Sandberg is CEO oh into people saying
that founders can keep going because
what happened in the 90s was founders
were quickly replaced by professional
CEOs if they raised any venture capital
because often the venture capitalists
would take over the board pretty quickly
often at the series a and what that
meant is that founders were
often demoted and they bring in sort of
the old gray haired person to run the
thing and I think that really shifted in
the era of Zuckerberg where suddenly
people said wow you can build massive
companies with the founder CEO still
driving it and if you actually looked at
the history of the biggest technology
companies I was always true Intel was
always driven by its founders Microsoft
was always driven by its founders we
surly on first 10 20 years you know
Dowell was driven by its founder and so
anecdotally actually founder CEOs worked
really well especially if they're able
to make control and not raise external
capital or if they raise it on very good
terms when they didn't give up control
but the second they give up control in
the 90s they'd be out like Steve Jobs
Steve Jobs you know the the founders of
Yahoo didn't run the company the
founders of eBay didn't run the company
like you can go through all the major
companies that I need founders of Google
had Eric Schmidt come in so you know up
until the Zaca moment I think it wasn't
a very common practice
um so most of the folks here in stirrups
cooler are in very very early-stage
companies let's talk about what it's
like in the early stage if you can think
back to mixer labs and and even color
how did how did you think of you were
the CEO of both those companies how did
you think about what should have most of
your attention during that time I think
the singular thing that really matters
is product market fit so building
something the customers that want and
that's the that's really honestly the
only thing that truly truly matters now
to get there it means you have to hire
people unless you can build it all
yourself and sell it all yourself it
means that you have to raise money if
you can't fund it off of your customers
or if you can't just bootstrap it and
you know the but but when all said and
done you need to build in salt product
and in the very early days that's really
the core thing you may yeah we we've
talked a lot about about product market
fit and finding product market fit in in
start-up school and one of the most
common questions that everyone asks is
how do you know when you have it it's
it's not so obvious it seems yeah I
think it's obvious if you think about it
the right way but I think it's it's very
hard to otherwise so I'll give you three
examples of signs that you have product
market fit from three
different companies you know if your
product is broken and people are still
using it very actively or you have high
retention on a broken product that's a
clear sign of product market fit when
Twitter was constantly going down in the
farewell days and yet nobody moved off
of Twitter that was a sign of just raw
market adoption a second sign is if
you're a SAS company and you have major
brands finding and using you organically
and paying for your product that's a
sign up product market fit so examples
of that would be pager duty which had I
think Apple is an early customer
there's Zeppelin which had I think
Facebook using them very early air table
has all sorts of brands that have just
sort of adopted it so I think there's a
number of sort of more recent breakout e
companies where big brands are just
showing up and starting to pay and I
think that's a clear sign of product
market fit the last one is just you know
whether you have very strong customer
feedback even from a small group of
people so at color for example very
early on we were getting effectively
love letters from our customers the
company colors started off focused on
providing people with information about
their hereditary risk of certain
genetically driven cancers and we were
getting emails from people where they
were saying thank you so much for
helping me for making this affordable so
saving their lives and for saving their
lives and say this is that you know they
felt that the color would help with that
and so you know we got very strong
customer feedback very early on it yeah
so it seems like it's some mix of and
again I think some of this is is
intuition but some mix of retention
customer feedback and you know maybe you
should break your product and see if
people keep on using it I think there's
a there's other metrics too so for
example people tend to discount
growth off of small bases even though
the growth is compounding so if you're
growing organically twenty percent a
month even if you're going from a
hundred to 120 users that is a real sign
a product market fit that a lot of
people tend to ignore or not believe
because they're like oh the numbers are
small it doesn't matter but if you're
consistently adding 20 people and then
30 people and then 40 people a month
after a month that's usually a sign that
the thing is really going to work yeah
what this is a while ago but
what went wrong or what goes wrong for
companies during this phase when they're
trying to find product market fit yeah I
think almost everything you can imagine
can go wrong and so if you don't have
product market fit that may or may not
derail the company fair product market
fit then you know it kind of matters
less although you still want to correct
those things you know I think for
example with mixer labs the very first
product was a wrong product so we
initially started off building almost
like content aggregation sites or wiki's
for locations and then we quickly
morphed it into an infrastructure
product we were selling infrastructure
to enable geolocation application so
this was before there was a big wave of
API companies and so it was one of the
first alongside things like Twilio or
you know some of the really early
Developer tool companies but the
starting point for the product was much
more of a consumer site that allowed you
to aggregate content and we'd built out
very deep infrastructure for that and
then we decided that really what we
should be doing is selling the
infrastructure so that was a good
example of us changing direction as a
start-up what else what else have you
seen go wrong at this this early stage
that might be instructive weather around
product market fit the the the folks you
hire the the even the sort of the
business moves the marketing moves you
might make early on yeah I think um you
know on the hiring side a lot of people
will let not great people stick around
for far too long and so and at my first
startup we actually let somebody go
within the first month one of our first
six or seven employees and you know the
person was great and they did well in
their career after but it just wasn't a
good fit relative to what we were
looking for as a company at the time so
I think there's a there's an old adage
that you should either hire extremely
well or fire very well optimally you do
both and I think a lot of people
tolerate a bad hire for way too long
but wait six seven eight months and say
hey we have to give them another chance
another chance but really you want to
have an initial feedback conversation
see if they react maybe you have one
more and then you have to take action
and I think the way you should think
about your startup from a hiring
perspective is it's almost like a life a
life raft you know your boat is sinking
and you're on this little raft and
there's five spots and you who are in
those five spots and if the people on
the raft
aren't the five people that you should
have on the raft you should find the
five people because you can only support
so much from a burn perspective or a
Productivity perspective or coordination
perspective so I think that's a very
important mindset to be in in terms of
who's on your team so this some might be
a hard question to answer but I was sort
of thinking about you know a lot of
times we focus on what goes wrong a lot
of things go wrong you guys have seen
out there things go wrong you've
invested in so many epic companies and
your companies have done great what goes
right in those like what stands out is
the set of things that people are doing
or steps they're taking that kind of
gives you that clue that this might be
one of those great companies yeah I
think the focus on customers and what
customers need very early is an
important signal and then I think
building something immediately is really
important to now that doesn't mean you
shouldn't be doing analysis you should
absolutely be thinking about the market
you should be thinking about your market
strategy you should be asking if your
customers are in defining out your
segments but you should also just build
stuff and try it and start to see
reactions rapidly and I think where I've
seen a lot of people fail is they Wade
and Wade and Wade in terms of actually
building something and sometimes they
just wait too long or you see these
companies that stay in stealth mode for
three four years and you're like that's
a terrible sign because you're not
actually getting real customer feedback
potentially the fuse like there's also
something about iterating fast in these
in these these great companies where
there's always something new and better
and and it's always better - yeah I
think that's definitely true the other
thing I've seen some people do which I
think actually helps a lot is from day
one they focus on the velocity of the
team and so they maybe focus on the
build environment early and making it so
that anybody can run a full instance of
the product with a single line of code
just to set it up right there are
actually things that you can do to make
your team dramatically more productive
that a lot of people don't do and so
anytime they on board somebody it takes
them two weeks to get the damn thing
running on their laptop instead of
actually saying how do we make it so
that any incremental person who hires or
any time we push a change we can
instantly see its effect so I think
there's almost like little things you
can do along the way there - yeah since
almost all the companies that we're
talking to are driven by human capital
people don't pay enough attention to
making that human capital as
effective and efficient as possible so
speaking of human capital you were CEO
and in both your companies and in fact
you've given a lot of advice to CEOs
both as an investor and in in
high-growth handbook but later on you
advising seals and other executives how
to be most effective how do you think
about that for early-stage startups yeah
I think for an early-stage startup you
know ultimately the focus should be on
how do you make your team as effective
as possible if you have a team and
effective means two things one is people
are all moving in the same direction and
there's clear goals and there's clear
sense of what you're actually building
and why but also you know it means tear
point iterating quickly it means talking
to customers early it means again
focusing on product market fit because I
think the mistake that people make is
you could have a happiest most wonderful
group of people in the world but if you
never find product market fit your
company is going to die because you're
just not gonna have the revenue to
support it or the cash to support it or
you'll be able to raise more money and
so you know whether you have kombucha or
not is secondary to just like building
something that people really want and I
think people get distracted along the
entrepreneurial journey either in terms
of eventually if they get funded and
they get invited to all these events and
all these other things start to distract
them you know there's a lot of sort of
entrepreneurial distractions that could
get your attention when really the core
thing is are people buying your product
and at what scale and are you growing
that at a good rate now that's if you're
on the venture track and you want truly
a high-growth sorta breakout company
there's all sorts of other startups you
could start you could start a lifestyle
business and that could be great there's
a variety of different reasons to do a
startup and so part of it too is asking
yourself what do you actually care about
is a founder and what's your objective
and then are your actions actually
mapping against those objectives I think
too many people just go on a default
path that isn't the right path for them
what should a CEO be spending most of
their time doing I think it differs
early versus late for an early company
it's going to be building so are you
actually helping to build the product
and you may not be the person that
should be building the product I'm
saying
one or two of you you're probably
building or selling second is hiring so
you know and making sure that the team
is productive and focused on the right
direction and then third making sure
that you don't run out of money lastly I
mean it's avoiding fights with your
co-founders and things like that like I
often say that an early stage startup
lot largely fails for three reasons or
only has to do three things you know one
is you need to find product market fit
which is incredibly hard you need to
make sure that you have the money to
survive and you need to not fight with
your co-founder because that will slow
everything down and for an early-stage
startup that's ultimately everything you
need to do and you need to hire and you
know there's different aspects of
selling that you really need to focus on
selling investors selling customers
selling hires but as either build or
sell for a late-stage company it gets
way more complicated you're still
selling for all sorts of reasons but
then you're also much more focused on
how do I enable this thing to scale in
terms of processes in terms of people
Ohio I hire executives how do i
internationalize how do i launch new
products how do i buy companies and then
you realize quickly that that has to be
a team effort
because no one person can do all those
things and so then you really start
asking okay how do I build out and
manage a really effective team one of
the the hard rules that a CEO has I
suppose is to figure out when you don't
have product market fit whether you need
to tweak the product or you need to do
more of a pivot and you mentioned that
it makes your labs you guys had to do a
pivot hop a lot of people ask that
question like how do you know like what
what when do you know that you've hit
the wall with what you're doing and you
need to do a more significant shift yeah
it's really hard because you do most
startups build something for six months
to a year they launch it and then they
hit a wall and then the question is is
that a real wall or is that a fake wall
and I think it's incredibly hard to know
I think if you're three four years into
something and you're just not seeing any
traction or momentum you've clearly
waited too long there's counter examples
of that and they're always going to be
kinder examples so for example TomTom
the European GPS company that ended up
for a while being one of the most
valuable companies in Europe I think it
was literally four people in a room for
like six years iterating through
different ideas until they came up with
a concept of doing GPS as which of
course now we're subsumed by phones
but they took a really long time to get
there
most of the companies that I've seen
work tend to work early at least in
terms of adoption or at least in terms
of some core metrics and so I think it's
possible that in today's environment
where capital is really loose people
actually wait too long to pivot or to
shut down because they can keep raising
more money and actually think that's a
bad thing because it's locking up great
people at the height of their creative
point in their lives
and preventing them from going and doing
something else so I do think at some
point you need to have that really frank
assessment and maybe you do it
periodically but should we really keep
going and then if we're gonna keep going
I think the key question is when you
pivot the one thing I would advocate is
being willing to restart completely
because typically when people pivot they
pivot within the same market versus
across markets and if you're in a bad
market that means we're gonna die
because you're just gonna go on to the
next thing you say hey we have all this
sunk costs and you start iterating on
that new thing and it doesn't work you
sort of a decision between an evaluation
of the market being bad versus is just
you have the wrong product could be
great market and bad product but yeah
you should assess it from first
principles and then if you decide that
you're done with the business you have
three options you shut it down you sell
or you pivot if you sell my suggestion
would be sell to somebody that's clearly
breaking out I think I've heard you say
before that speaking of being in a great
market that that's sort of your
fundamental test if you believe that
there's this incredible market
opportunity you want to be in there you
want to be fighting that fight and you
know even if you don't know the right
product at first you can find it yeah I
think the singular determinants of
startup success is the market and it's
not the strength of the team and so I
think a lot of people talk about how
great teams will always figure it out
and I've seen great team after great
team and a terrible market just die
because they're in a bad market so they
never have the opportunity or the time
to really figure it out or to iterate as
much as they could if they were in a
very good market where there's just you
know cash inflows hitting you despite
what you're doing and so you know
there's the anti rattle off one of the
founders of benchmark has what some
people now call rock lifts law which is
you know great team terrible market
market wins so it doesn't matter how
good the
team is if the markets awful terrible
team great market market wins you could
actually be not very good at what you're
doing and still do very well your
products have broken but is still
getting massive adoption because you're
in a great market and then there's great
team great market something magical
happens which is like a Google or
Facebook where you had people who then
executed they added new product lines
and they were really great at what they
were doing in terms of scaling it to the
next level so I do think that's very
true and I've seen many many great teams
just die in a terrible market and then
I've seen a few bad teams like do very
well and that to me was very surprising
it feels very non a gala terian or
merit-based
you know why do you think it is that so
many teams choose such bad markets I
think it's maybe three reasons one is
sometimes people just jump into things
and they just start building without
actually thinking it through and
sometimes that works really well because
it's a product you want or need and so
you're building it for everybody else
but sometimes it's something that you
know has been tried many many times
before and that doesn't mean it won't
work in the future but maybe you should
look at the history and ask why didn't
it work and what should I be doing
differently versus just doing the same
thing again that's failed five times the
second thing I've seen a lot of people
fail out is what I'd call multi miracle
startups so I think every startup needs
at least one miracle to succeed because
if it was obvious that it was going to
work
everybody would already be doing it and
so you wouldn't have an opportunity so
in some sense startups only have
opportunities and markets that are non
obvious which means they have to
overcome some obstacle the distribution
needs to magically work or the product
and the price point need to magically
work or whatever it is but there's some
companies where they come up with two
miracles for their startup they say our
stage one of the startup is we're gonna
do X and then stage Y is we're gonna do
this other thing that's completely
unrelated but because we did X we can
certainly do y and usually those fail
because you're saying well you have two
miracles and you're compounding very low
probabilities so you're just bound to
fail an example would be there is an era
where people said that the way to
compete with Yelp was to start an events
product which is an open space winning
events and then it's adjacent enough to
what Yelp does that you could add local
listings then you'd win in local
listings and that's a terrible approach
you should say either r1o and in events
and just double down on that or I want
to go after listings and then I'm just
going to do that but this sort of
multi-step thing tends to fail which is
I think
lesson in how not to approach your
investor meetings if you're talking to
an investor and you have a whole bunch
of miracles that have to happen before
your big company then that investor is
probably not going to be that interested
yeah the most common miracle that's
quoted today is data mode people say
well we'll generate tons of data and
then we'll be differentiated and that I
think in genomics something like that
could work but outside of that I
actually think I've never seen a company
pull that off in terms of a broader you
know data is the only thing that's their
asset and they're gonna somehow do
something with that asset yeah or we're
gonna get our AI is gonna have get the
smartest because we'll have the most
data and then our AI will be the best
and therefore we'll win yeah just back
to the CEO question how should teams
choose their CEO who should be the CEO
it's a good question
I mean there's different ways that you
could describe or argue it and
ultimately in some cases it's clear hey
this person is the person we're choosing
in some cases it's a huge argument I
think the most important thing is to
resolve it even if you get it wrong
because you can always correct the wrong
thing but at least you have somebody in
charge I think a lot of founding teams
end up with a lot of fights that then
slow down the company dramatically if
they don't have somebody clearly in
charge you know I think if it's a very
technical product it's often better to
have the technologist in charge so say
that you had a business person a
technologist because if it's two
technologists I don't know how to
differentiate between you know who they
may be somebody who's a little bit
better at selling or recruiting or you
know that part of the job maybe that's
the right person for the CEO if it's two
technologists if it's a business person
and a salesperson and a technologist
usually the business person is gonna be
better at those things but that doesn't
necessarily mean they should be the CEO
because often the iteration of the
product and the understanding of the
product is driven by the technologist
and that really impacts how you sell it
how you iterate on it and the decisions
that you make along the way but honestly
I think any configuration can work you
know and I think sometimes a founding
pair will be very self honest and I'll
just be like oh this person is better
the things that we need from the CEO
today which means better at recruiting
better fundraising better at selling and
better
sort of setting vision and direction
then it's a clear shot in terms like we
should be you might even say that you
should put in in the position of the CEO
the person who's going to help you find
product market fit who's gonna drive the
product market fit sooner and better
that's a good point
yeah I wonder yeah why were you the CEO
because it was your idea because yeah
you know it's interesting I so for
example with color I stepped down as CEO
after four years and the origin of the
company was a bit of a mix but
ultimately it was driven by my
co-founders personal story where you
know he himself as a brca2 carrier his
mother's had breast cancer twice is that
members of his family died of the
disease and so the company was started
in some sense as a form of patient
advocacy where we said it's ridiculous
that people can't afford an access he's
really important pieces of genetic
information that can really drive what
they should be doing from a health
perspective in their lives so you know I
think that was hit it's it's his passion
and his drive more than it was his
passion and drive I mean I had a lot of
passion for it having worked in biology
and things but fundamentally I think one
of the reasons the shift we made is so
good is because you know this is
something that he's truly lived and
cares about deeply and I think that
really comes with comes through as well
in the choices that are made in the
product and how do you think about
patient data privacy and how do you
think about all these things and I think
he had a very deep intuitive sense of
what it would mean for him which I think
was very important in the context of
what color was doing it seems like a
very modern way to look at the CEO as
the ultimate product advocate the Steve
Jobs being the obvious yeah example
there and I think and tech were very
imprinted on that style but there's also
great examples of CEOs who are amazing
sales people you know Benioff started
off in sales and I think Oracle or
something right and so there's all sorts
of examples of non technology CEOs
who've done extremely well or you have a
situation where you do a mix like at
Google Eric Schmidt had a PhD in CS but
he'd also run an eval before and you
know he'd run a public company and so it
was somebody who done the business side
of things as well as the technical side
yeah I haven't figured out whether it's
a trend or not but it seems a little bit
that way I always find that I prefer if
I'm looking at
in a company or looking at a company for
YC that a product person that the CEO
really has a feel for the product anyway
yeah I totally agree so um let's
transition a little bit to fundraising
we've been talking a fair amount about
that recently in start-up school can you
I don't know did you have interesting
experiences fundraising that you can
talk about in your in your two companies
and mixer labs in color sure you know we
took a very different fundraising
strategy for the first startup that we
did we ended up raising from seed from a
branding venture fund plus a bunch of
angels and then we did a second round
from sort of a super angel or small fun
group and you know the the biggest issue
we had there as we had a bad investor
who as we were exiting the company
basically tried to call more value for
themselves as part of our exit and this
is sort of a Midas list investor is very
well known now and the second company my
cook this is a successful investor who
tried to screw other people over while
the yeah and there Nate know I'm always
tempted yeah I stopped myself but I do
think that there are some brand name
investors who are dicks right and so you
should be careful in terms of who you
work with and you should diligence them
and ask the founders where either things
didn't go well or where there was some
issue over time or whatever it is and
that's more likely to reveal the truth
about an investor than asking in a
situation where everything worked so we
like to say oh I see that being nice is
is a big advantage but it doesn't always
work
yeah I'm times it's not true yeah and I
think um I would differentiate between
two things I think you want investors
who will push you like or question what
you're doing maybe is a better way to
phrase it because I do see some founders
sometimes uncomfortable with being asked
about some of their decisions and you
should be asked about your decisions
like that's the way to get better and it
may be a naive question that an investor
asked but that may be the thing that
makes you think about something that you
should be doing differently or maybe it
just reaffirms what they what you're
doing is right right and so I would
differentiate between that and somebody
acting badly in terms of calling value
for themselves or doing other things so
I'm
we did have you know we had a pool of
investors whose only one who acted badly
out of a dozen people so it's not you
know were 15 people or something so how
easy was it to raise money at mixture
labs your first company yeah it took us
about 2 or 3 months in general I think
you hear the news about these
fundraisers that happen in a week and
you think every fundraiser is going to
take a week but if you're actually being
a thoughtful on your site as well as
should take a couple months because
otherwise you're not getting to know the
people that you're fundraising from so I
and usually what happens is you'll find
that until somebody really tips most
people are scared to jump in which is
really weird right and general you'll
find that most investors are fear driven
versus ambition driven they're kind of
scared of missing something versus
really excited and believe vigorously in
something and so high conviction
investors are actually very valuable in
my opinion right they're few and far
between it's it's it's hard to be the
first money in a company you have to
just really believe especially with a
new founder yeah and a lot of investors
fall for the opposite of that which is
there's a brand name investor in and so
they go in but it's actually a bad
investment yeah because everybody makes
mistakes
they're sheep yeah how about with color
was it a you own a successful
entrepreneur already you're a well-known
executive at that point and so you were
sort of in a different spot raising for
color yeah I think for many founders on
their second company it's much easier
because they have relationships and so
my co-founder and I did most of our seed
and then we brought in people for the a
and as people that we'd known for a
while and that we were really trusted
and respected for and so we had Joe
Lonsdale and Ben owed from Khosla
Ventures come in for a for the c4 mixer
labs we really had to network to get
intros and so we met Michael Dearing as
he was just starting to invest so we one
of the first companies he invested in
and we met him through Kim Scott who
with the book radical candor I worked
with her at Google and so I just asked
people I know who do you know that's
investing right now and then we ended up
having Sequoia and the round Reed
Hoffman when he was still an individual
and evolved from Angela's so we had a
bunch of really great
people line up but we had to network for
the first view and you know I think it
was Dearing maybe who tipped first or
somebody else and then everybody kind of
catalyzed so how does someone get a
meeting with a lot Gil I think you make
it sound like that's a valuable thing
but I think well it depends whether
those companies that you invested in
would have been successful without your
investment maybe it's the most valuable
thing you can get I think that the most
successful companies and 95% of the
cases are successful despite their
investors
I shouldn't say despite I should say
irregardless you know the investors may
help optimize certain things they may
bring in the key exec and I'm not trying
to minimize the impact of investors
I just think product market fit is such
a raw force that it's helpful to have
people around you who can help with
scaling and other things and I've seen
companies go the other way where they
have a lot of bad capital all the way
through all their rounds and the
founders are drowning for help and so
you really do see a difference I'm not
saying that there isn't a difference
actually I know one company in
particular where they had a series of
initial weak investors and their board
meetings are completely ineffectual they
haven't gotten a lot of help they
haven't both had an executive team like
it shows and so I'm not saying that I'm
just saying to get from zero to one it's
not your investors who will do it most
of the time there are some counter
examples like I think Paul Graham helped
actually with some of the very early
ideas for reddit really especially but
I'm pretty unusual for an investor be
transformative for a company yeah so
getting that meaning I think the best
way is to get an introduction through a
founder that I already know or somebody
else that I already know so that it's in
network I think if you can't find a way
to do that then you're probably not
going to find a way to get customers
you're not going to find a way to get
hires you're not going to find a way to
do all sorts of things so I think that's
the best way yeah it seems like Paul
Graham's original idea of doing things
that don't scale works across different
domains and not just building product
but figuring out I get to the right
investor and get that first yeah it's a
different component of them
everything you end up doing as a
start-up hiring is also not going to be
scalable early and you're just gonna
have to grind through giant lists of
people so for example a color you know
because we are a CLIA cap lab and we're
focused on the regulatory compliance of
what we do we had to hire specialists
called CLS's into the lab very early
because they had licenses that allowed
them to operate certain types of tests
in the state of California we could only
find two or three hundred CLS's total
and we had to hire two or three of them
so we had to hire 1% of all of these
people in the state of California and we
wanted to find people who are very good
if you have a license
that's very rare it means you can get
hired really easily which doesn't
necessarily mean that you're great and
so we I literally ground through 200
people you know we we put them all on a
spreadsheet and I I in the recruiter I
work with contacted every one of those
200 people and had a conversation with
all of them so you just have to grind
through stuff it's hard work doing a
start-up huh that's why I'm taking a
break yeah so there's so much I want to
talk about well do it we'll have a few
more things and then we'll open it up
for questions you sort of already
answered this a little bit but maybe you
can elaborate on your decision process
when you're looking at an investment
yeah I think I have three really simple
criteria and they're gonna sound very
generic but I think about them deeply
hopefully the first one is market so it
our product market is a better way to
phrase it are they is the team building
something that the product will actually
want or need and there's different ways
to check that it could be something that
I would have used myself at my company
it could be you see clear growth
retraction from something that's
launched or sometimes I'll literally
call potential customers and ask them so
I actually do a lot of market that will
judge for things I invest and even
though I'm just an angel the second
thing is you know are they are they
people who are very high caliber they
can learn quickly you know all the rest
of it so there is the founder component
which I think is really important I just
think the market dominates that and then
lastly you know if they were to call me
at 10 o'clock at night on a Friday or
Saturday night when I take the call and
would be excited to talk with them are
they good people are they ethical would
it be easy to work with because life is
short and there's lots of companies that
will work and the last thing you want is
long conversation with somebody terrible
that's true so um what what are the um
what are the things you see companies
doing wrong when they come and meet with
you ah good question I think it's a few
things one is not getting down to the
details quickly enough so sometimes
people will have the preamble of their
personal story how when they were seven
they lived in Canada and you know then
they were nine and then they were eleven
and they started learning you know to
write code and then something else
happened and then eventually they came
up with the idea in college but they
didn't work on it for seven years well
so I would just make it a very crisp
concise story this is what we're
building this is why we're building this
is who I am but like here are the three
highlights here's who my co-founders are
you know here's the market that we're in
here's a product we're building let's
show you a demo like that would be sort
of the optimal early stage conversation
because the demo means they actually
built something instead of just talked
about it the quick analysis of the
market / how does this fit in or what's
the use case is really important because
I've thought through that dynamic and
then the team who are you what do you
care about why you building this is
important versus I was 7 and revelation
mountains get to the point in other
words I get to the point quickly and
also make efficient use of time so if
the meeting should only take 20 minutes
that's great what I found is that very
busy people will spend more time with
you if you're very efficient with their
time because they don't feel that you're
just gonna sit there and take up the
time because they can and so I've had
meetings where I'll tell you one example
meeting which I thought was like amazing
and I didn't think it would happen so I
was looking into funding things and sort
of anti-aging or longevity related
technologies I think it's a big gap in
biopharma and I think it's important
socially and there is this founder Ben
Kamen's who I met with and we had like I
think 45 minutes set up and we talked
for 10 minutes and at the end of 10
minutes he said okay I got everything I
need out of you I'm gonna go think about
this stuff and then I'll follow up in
four days and I was like okay this guy's
just going to disappear like nobody does
a 10 minute
eating and actually comes back with
anything useful and then he came back in
four days with this big analysis of
everything that we discussed and what he
was going to do next and I was gonna
approach it and that was a 15 20 minute
meeting and I was like oh my gosh this
person is amazing you know they're
extremely efficient they have amazing
follow-through they say what they're
gonna do and they do it and they realize
that you know this is a multi
interaction thing and therefore how do I
build that confidence in that person
that they actually want to keep talking
to me that's a great lesson for future
investors too huh yeah I like that so I
want to turn over for 2qa but just
before we do that you just wrote a book
high growth handbook which i think is a
fantastic book maybe not so relevant to
running a startup although it seems like
there's a way to sort of track back from
all the lessons in there and think and
it helps you think about your startup I
think in an effective way
yeah so the book is called the high
growth handbook and it's basically
almost like a section by section view of
a lot of the common things that happen
in startups and then tactically what to
do about them so it's a very tactical
book that doesn't have a lot of
platitudes like there's nothing about a
players hiring a players which doesn't
really help anybody it's not like
somebody's gonna write I'm in a player
on their resume but it really helps you
understand okay you want to build a
recruiting process what's the multi-step
process you should build and how should
you go about doing it and then it's
inter woven with interviews with you
know Sam from yce
and Claire Hughes Johnson from stripe
and Marc Andreessen and Reid Hoffman and
Ritchie's song B and a bunch of other
people around their experiences
operating or funding companies that are
relevant to each section you know so
they'll be a section on board and then
there'll be an interview with Reid
Hoffman around what he looks for in
board members and he just wrote boot
scaling which is sort of a really
interesting book around scaling
companies that I definitely recommend as
well so the interesting thing is that a
number of the sections in the book
actually started off as blog posts on my
blog and some of them were actually
targeted to early stage founders so some
of the stuff around hiring maps into it
or some of the stuff around product
management it Maps into it so I do think
there are some things that are universal
and then here points some things that
are completely divorced like
you know buying a company or raising 100
million dollars or whatever it is are
obviously for much later stages we're
doing a bigger reward you know things
like that the way the books structured
it turns out it's easy to skip around so
you should buy the book thanked find the
parts you like so let's open to Q&A
questions for a lot of would be the
question the question is about investor
updates how frequent should they be and
what should be in them yeah I have a
blog post actually wrote on this and I
think that you should do it monthly and
my suggestion in terms of the sections
would be the top section should be what
are your ass from your investors or
investors and advisors or whoever you're
sending it to so it's very clear
immediately how they can help so if they
don't read it anything else if they just
open the email they'll see that and
you'll actually get a lot of responses
to that
I think the second section could be
metrics if you have metrics it could be
sales and it could be that it's flat and
that's fine right
I think burn is important to include so
how much money do you have left Paul
Graham often advocates for default dead
or default alive are you gonna run out
of money at some point or not I often
just phrase it similarly is like how
many months of cash do you have left and
have how much how much you're burning
and then you can have updates around
team around market etc a product did you
launch anything new press that you get
any so I think you can follow that the
reason I think monthly is important is
you want to create high enough frequency
that your investors were thinking about
you and that they feel that they're up
to speed on things but not so much that
it overwhelms you or them and I think
monthly is a nice cadence a color we
started sending out investor updates
really early and I'd call up an investor
and they would and I'd start to give
them background in terms of what's been
happening they say no no no I read your
update I know what's going on let's jump
straight to it and so by being very
transparent it actually helped immensely
in terms of not spending the first 20
minutes getting people up to speed but
every investor calls suddenly was very
efficient and they loved the
transparency because they feel like
they're part of the company and the team
and that you're open with them yeah
market first investment strategy so how
did you evaluate an obvious market like
that IBM need back in 2010 how did you
so the question is about market
opportunities since a lot cares most
about that how do you evaluate
opportunities that are non obvious like
you're being B yeah so I invested in
their a versus her seed I'm guessing the
seed was harder I think at their a they
had pretty clear traction I mean they
were growing at a good clip and then the
other side of it was I had actually
traveled on a service called service
which so after World War two the
Esperanto community thought that one way
to encourage World Peace was to let
people stay with each other for free and
you'd apply to be a traveler and they
literally give you you do interviews and
then they give you these little booklets
if you're traveling to Italy it lists
everybody in Italy who would be willing
to host you and their phone number and
how to contact them and you'd literally
call random strangers up or email them
and say hey can I stay with you
and how long can I stay with you and
just stayed with them for free so I
traveled on a very similar service
throughout Europe so from you is a
no-brainer I thought wow you can
monetize this and the most expensive
asset that a person has is their home
and so if you can help people monetize
their homes and make a lot of money off
of it it actually felt like a no brainer
but part of that was driven
experientially and then part of it was
it was working more questions yeah yeah
I would basically the question is about
can you talk about due diligence on
investors who necessarily give you a bad
reference yeah I think it's a I would
just look most of them will have a list
of investments either on their website
or an angel list or CrunchBase and so I
would just and if you're part of YC I
think there's Bookface which has all
sorts of them foreign investor database
yeah they have an investor database so
you can actually see what everybody says
about them a lot is a good grade
hopefully and
so I would just look at that list and
then call the two or three things that
you've never heard of or that shut down
or were small acquisitions or whatever
it may be
I mean sometimes you'll call a
successful company too and they'll say
I'll never work with this person again I
know one company and you can actually
see it so say that somebody exits their
company for a billion dollars and then
they start another company and in no
rounds do they take their prior
investors that's usually a sign and so I
would call up that person any advice on
pricing yeah Marc Andreessen has a this
great quote which if he had to tell
startup founders one thing I think he
says that you would tell him to raise
prices and so I think in general
especially technology driven companies
tend to really under price their product
under the belief that if they price it
really low it'll get them more market
share more rapidly and therefore they'll
win the market when in reality they've
never run the experiment and it's really
easy to drop prices it's really hard to
raise them and it's very hard to raise
them I do think that people also
overthink pricing and the changes and
the impact of them when they have small
populations if you have 100 customers
that are all small customers and you
raise prices and piss him off that's
okay I mean you have to do it nicely or
maybe you grandfather they're men
there's all sorts of ways you can do it
the right way but I'm just saying it's
not an existential moment for the
company unlike if you have a hundred
thousand customers or you have giant
enterprises using you and you're you're
going into these deep negotiations so I
think when you have a very small base
you can actually experiment you can a/b
test things you can do all sorts of
things but in general I would start on
the high end unless your strategy is
explicitly to go for market share and
there's a reason for doing that and
there are certain markets where that's
very important certain retail certain
areas where you really are generating a
data asset like those may be places
where you want to have low pricing you
know often people will just look at
their competitors websites and say oh
they're charging $9.99 a month I should
too but often that company hasn't really
thought anything through either unless
older more sophisticated companies so
again I think I would just sort of start
from scratch and there's there's long
things around you doing value-based
pricing or you know cost based pricing
or you know there's different ways to
price products and I think Michael
Dearing has a great online tutorial
which I would definitely look up you can
do a search for it like Michael Dearing
pricing and there will be a variety of
different segments and approaches the
other thing you can do on the pricing
side is good better best is a common
framework so you have a base product you
have an intermediate product and then
you have the high end product and the
high end product exists largely so that
people buy the intermediate product so
there's all sorts of pricing tactics
that tend to work I think the question
is around especially in consumer markets
how can you tell what's wrong with the
product is that your strategy or is it
the content or is it some feature of the
product that's missing
it depends a little bit on what type of
consumer product is so if you have an
e-commerce site it really is about LT
being cat can you acquire customers at a
cost less than what you sell the product
to to them and what's the lifetime value
of that customer and there there's a
very small handful of distribution
strategies that tend to work via SEO or
SEM or other types of either ad formats
or customer acquisition strategies you
know if it's more of a social network
then really it's looking at growth rates
in churn and what are the vectors by
which you're pulling people in to the
product so can get I think there's a
dozen different answers depending on the
market segment Andrew Chen has some
really good blog posts I think about it
about some of the stuff so it may be a
good reference to go look on okay one
more question back there
in terms of product market fit what do
you consider how can you tell the
difference between an actual wall where
you're about to get smashed or a fake
wall that you should smash through I
think every start of the succeeds has
fake walls so to some extent I think is
back to the the discussion we had
earlier which is what is a sign that
your products actually working and it
depends on what you mean by a wall in
terms of you know so for example if
you're growing 20% a month off of a
small base I think that's a sign that
it's working even though people may say
oh you have a small user base you're
hitting a wall because you know you're
never gonna get that big and then you
see these companies become giant
companies because the use case is much
broader Airbnb is a good example where I
think that market size was bigger than
anybody expected so it depends a little
bit on what sort of wall you're talking
about but I do think there are clear
signs that something is gonna work and
often they're ignored by the founders
themselves because it's just such a leap
of faith to think the small delicate
thing that you're working on that's a
very breakable will actually turn into
this amazing giant company that actually
happened to me when I went to Airbnb s
Christmas party a few years ago and you
know I invested when it was about eight
people and then I went to the Christmas
party and there was like I don't
remember how many 2000 people or
whatever the numbers at that time
dressed in suits and it looked extremely
like a very nice corporate holiday event
I was like oh my god this is amazing
it was no it was one of those moments
where you're like wow this this really
happens you know it you can go from
eight people to thousands over a couple
years and build substantial institution
that's gonna survive potentially
generationally you know that's very
powerful well I thank you very much
ah thanks rather
you
you